any Democrat that actually thinks well I
want to nominate him is a fool
how many times I mean Jimmy Carter
wanted to run against Ronald Reagan and
Ronald Reagan beat him in a landslide
and Hillary wanted to run against Donald
Trump
we know what happened right
so I don't I don't buy that one I do I
do buy the fact that they want to uh
stop him
whenever and however they can so you
don't think it's that strategic to want
to eliminate the Santas as a candidate
because on some polls it shows better
when DeSantis goes against Biden that he
can beat him but Trump against Biden he
can that's what a lot of uh polls are
saying I don't think right maybe it'll
maybe eventually will be that as we get
closer to the election it's too early to
know who can beat who well no we brought
you here to tell us we want to know now